boc s'il vous plaît
cet homme s'appelle boc jacques boc un
nom pas toujours facile à porter surtout
si l'on ait des barlagne
[Musique]
on me demandait tout le temps un box
s'il vous plaît ça m'agace est vraiment
beaucoup parce que j'ai entendu des
centaines et des centaines de feux
du coup jacques box amy a photographié
des gens comme lui des gens dont le
patronyme évoque le métier qu'ils
exercent
on appelle ça des apd au nimh et ces
exemples d'actes au nez lors j'allais y
en a beaucoup mais dans ce que j'ai
commencé à photographier j'ai fait
monsieur cochonneau alors monsieur
cochonneau et charcutiers ensuite j'ai
fait le docteur bobos
il ya aussi à ça c'est extraordinaire
c'est une infirmière qui qui me dit vous
savez j'ai pas grand chose à dire mais
quand j'étais petit je me souviens mes
professeurs m'ont toujours dit même et
institua m'ont toujours dit tu as dit à
deux métiers qui fera pas dans la vie
ces couturières et infirmières et elle
me dit je suis infirmière elle s'appelle
mademoiselle piquemal
[Musique]
jacques n'est pas avare de kilomètres
pour chasser la pta nîmes mais que ce
soit par l'annuaire ou par le bouche à
oreille il ne suffit pas de le trouver
il faut encore le convaincre
la grande difficulté c'est que
finalement je
trouve à photographier des gens
mais qui n'ont jamais pensé que l'on
pourrait parler d'eux
selon les gens bien je sais que de faire
des unes des recherches un petit peu
satellitaire autour des gens pour savoir
qu'elle est un peu leurs personnages
leur personnalité si c'est quelqu'un qui
est marrant d'emblée bon que tout se
passe bien je givet franco
il ya des gens franchement surtout dans
le milieu médical où certains officiers
ministériels
on pas trop envie
prenez cistes là dessus
lorsque l'estonie mais ferrer parfois il
n'en démord plus haut point que jacques
reviennent alors faire une nouvelle
séance photo pour peaufiner son oeuvre
regardez moi je m'appelle j'ai du boulot
gilbert j'ai du boulot ça soit pas
j'ai pensé que c'était ça allait bien
que mon nom c'est un peu normal quand on
a fait des boulots j'entends ça tous les
jours même au bistrot j'entends j'ai du
boulot mais je me retrouve qu'est ce que
vous voulez parler des gens pensent
toujours qu'ils parlent de moi mais non
j'ai pas de boulot
qu'est ce que vous aviez vous ai dit je
veux vous photographier devant le
panneau ça dure et il m'a photographié
mais sa durée de 8 heures à 11 heures et
demie j'ai compté 60 photos pour en
sortir une
vraie comptant dix cantons qui la fait
un soliste pas pour même vous dire j'ai
une amie au magasin là bas mon premier
ouvrier là où ils voulaient me l'a chopé
pour la mettre magasins et madame du
boulot la donne en ont vraiment que la
gale il faut tenter reibel il est pas
beau le petit a du boulot
tout
tout une
reste maintenant à s'interroger sur le
sens métaphysique de tout ça disons que
la question que je me pose toujours et
que tout le monde se pose est ce que
nombre de familles à influencer le choix
du métier je ne sais pas si un truc mais
il ya tous ces gens là doivent bien
avoir une maison qui leur est commune
un peu comme en 40 tandis que j'en parle
en connaissance de l'ensa de clauses à
force de dire un gamin je ne fais pas le
jacques
l'infanterie paraître polis ans
que ces gens là ils ont été
ils ont été influencés je sais pas et je
pense quelque chose c'est pas
ça me semble peu probable qu'ils aient
pas une raison qu'ils fassent qui est un
choix de mes tripes
quoi qu'il en soit et quel que soit
votre métier si vous faites partie de la
famille des anonymes n'hésitez pas à
vous faire connaître de ce bien curieux
photographe
[Musique]